foreign
to enable a computer system to
understand human language it must have a
way to represent knowledge and meaning
in a form that system can work with this
is where knowledge representation comes
in
knowledge representation involves
designing a formal approach to represent
knowledge in a way a computer can
process
in artificial intelligence knowledge
representation is the process of
presenting information about the real
world in a way that a computer system
can comprehend and use knowledge
representation aims to give computers a
method to reason about the real world
make choices and Reserve issues based on
the information that is available to
them natural language processing relies
heavily on the knowledge representation
since it gives the text Data a way to
represent and manipulate meaning NLP
deals with understanding and processing
human language which involves
understanding the meaning of words and
sentence in NLP knowledge representation
represents meaning in text Data such as
sentences paragraphs and documents this
representation enables NLP systems to
analyze and manipulate the meaning of
Text data in various ways such as
information retrieval question answering
text summarization sentiment analysis
and Mission translation overall
knowledge representation is a crucial
component of NLP because it gives text
Data with ability to represent and
manipulate meaning which is necessary
for computers to understand and process
human language of after all NLP is a
subfield of artificial intelligence that
deals with the interaction between
computers and humans using natural
language NLP involves in a wide range of
tasks such as text classification
Mission translation chatbots and many
more if you want to become an expert in
the field of AI and ml then take up the
professional certificate program in Ai
and ml by simplyler and master those
necessary skills check out the link in
the description for more details
knowledge representation is a critical
component of artificial intelligence and
a rapidly growing field there are many
exciting career opportunities available
for professionals with expertise in this
area some of the most popular career
paths in knowledge representation and AI
include AI engineer natural language
processing specialist EI researcher
knowledge engineer chatbot developer
data scientist and many more the average
base income of an AI engineer in India
is rupees 9 lakh 80 000 per year whereas
the average base pay of an AI engineer
in the United States is dollar
1285 per annum it's worth noting that AI
is a rapidly growing field in India as
there is a high demand for skilled
Professionals in this area which can
result in higher salaries and attractive
compensation package for qualified
candidates on that note welcome to the
simply learn YouTube channel today we
are here with an interesting video on
knowledge representation in EI without
any further delay let's have a look at
the agenda so first we'll start with
what is knowledge representation next
what kind of knowledge to represent in
AI advancing we will understand the
types of knowledge moving ahead let's
have a look at the AI knowledge cycle
and then the properties and finally the
approaches of knowledge representation
before going deep into the topic let us
understand knowledge representation with
an example so imagine you are organizing
a party and you need to keep a track of
your guest dietary restrictions so you
could represent this information in a
table that lists each guest and their
dietary restriction
so in this table each row represents a
guest and the column represent their
name and dietary restriction organizing
this information in a structured way
allows you to reference it as needed
throughout the party planning process
quickly so this is an example of
knowledge representation because you are
using a system to represent information
meaningfully that can be easily accessed
and used other example of knowledge
representation include using a graph to
represent relationships between concept
or a decision tree to represent a
decision making process now we got a
basic idea of what is knowledge
representation in EI so moving ahead
let's have a look at the various kinds
of knowledge that AI needs to represent
so first object so an object is a thing
or entity that can be identified and
described so for example a car a person
or a book are all objects
coming to events and event happens at a
specific time and place for example a
wedding a concert or a game or all
events next is performance performance
is a measure of how well a task is
accomplished for example in sports
performance might be how many points a
player scores or how fast a runner
completes a race
next we have meta knowledge So Meta
knowledge refers to knowledge about
knowledge it is the knowledge that
describes how other pieces of knowledge
are related to each other for example
knowing that a car is a type of vehicle
is an example of meta knowledge
next we have facts so facts are
statements that are true or false for
example this guy is blue is a fact
knowledge base a knowledge base is a
collection of knowledge and information
that is organized and stored in a
specific way for example a customer
information database is a type of
knowledge base to provide an example of
these Concepts consider the domain of a
car dealership in this domain an object
might be a specific car model such as
the Toyota Camry and even may be a test
driver or a purchase of a car so
performance might be how well a
salesperson can sell a specific car
model and meta knowledge suggests that
the Toyota Camry is a certain type a
fact might be that the Cadbury has a
particular fuel efficiency rating
finally the knowledge base might include
information about the customer
preference sales data and vehicle
specification so next let's discuss on
the types of knowledges first we have
declarative knowledge this is factual
knowledge about the world including
information about objects Concepts
events and relationships declarative
knowledge can be represented as a set of
propositions or statements
next we have procedural knowledge this
is knowledge about how to do things
including skills procedures and
techniques so procedural knowledge can
be represented as a set of rules or
algorithms
and next we have meta knowledge So Meta
knowledge refers to the knowledge that
describes or characterize other
knowledge it provides information about
other knowledge properties relationships
and context
next we have heuristic knowledge refers
to knowledge occurring those trial and
error and it often based on experienced
rather than formal rules or logical
reasoning
and finally we have structural knowledge
structural knowledge refers to the
organization and arrangement of
information or data meaningfully
structural knowledge is used to create
models that describes the relationships
between different concepts or entities
in knowledge representation so following
to this we have cycle of knowledge
representation in AI so perception so
perception is the process by which
information is gathered through the
sense and processed by the brain in the
context of knowledge representation
perception refers to the ability of an
AI system to sense and interact with the
real world and extract meaningful
information from it then we have
learning so learning is gaining new
knowledge skills or behavior through
experience study or instruction in the
context of knowledge representation
learning refers to the ability of a
system to occur new information and
modify its internal knowledge
representation based on that information
and then we have knowledge
representation and reasoning so
knowledge representation is creating a
model of knowledge in a computer system
that can be used for reasoning and
decision making the reasoning is used
that model to conclude make inferences
and solve problems so in the context of
knowledge representation the goal is to
represent knowledge in a way that it is
efficient and effective for reasoning
and then we have planning planning is
creating a sequence of actions to
achieve a goal in the context of
knowledge representation planning refers
to the ability of a system to create a
plan of action based on its internal
knowledge representation and finally we
have execution execution is a process of
carrying out a plan of action in the
context of knowledge representation
execution refers to the ability of the
system to implement a plan of action
based on its internal knowledge
representation and the environment
Factor it perceives now let's discuss
the properties different properties of
knowledge representation including
expressiveness a knowledge
representations system should be able to
express a wide range of Concepts and
relationships between them the next
property is inferential adequacy a
knowledge representation system should
support the ability to reason with the
represented knowledge the next property
is efficiency a knowledge representation
system should be able to manipulate and
retrieve knowledge efficiently
next transparency
a knowledge representation system should
be transferred to the user allowing them
to understand and modify the knowledge
quickly and finally scalability a
knowledge representation system should
be able to handle large amounts of data
and still maintain its efficiency and
expressiveness moving ahead let's have a
look at the approaches of knowledge
representation knowledge representation
is an essential aspect of artificial
intelligence that involves organizing
and structuring knowledge in a way that
computer systems can effectively utilize
there are different approaches of
knowledge representation in AI including
simple relational inheritable
inferential and procedural knowledge so
let's explore each of these approaches
of knowledge representation with an
example first we have SIMPLE relational
knowledge this type of knowledge
representation involves organizing
knowledge through relationships between
entities or objects simple relational
knowledge is typically a set of rules
defining the relationships between
different objects for example a simple
relational knowledge representation for
a family could be John is the father of
Mary Mary is the sister of Peter Peter
is the son of John next inheritable
knowledge inheritable knowledge
represents the knowledge that can be
passed on from one object or entity to
another so this type of knowledge
representation is often used to
represent hierarchical relationships
between objects for example an animal
that belongs to the class of mammals
inherits all the attributes of its
parent class so in this case the
inheritable knowledge is represented as
mammals are warm blooded animals dogs
are mammals therefore dogs are also
warm-bladed animals next inferential
knowledge inferential knowledge
represents knowledge derived from
another knowledge so this type of
knowledge representation is often used
to represent logical relationships
between objects for example in a medical
diagnosis system a doctor might infer a
patient's condition based on their
symptoms so the inferential knowledge is
represented as if a patient has a fever
and a cough they might have pneumonia
the patient has a fever and a cough
therefore the patient might have
pneumonia next procedural knowledge
procedural knowledge represents the
knowledge that involves a sequence of
actions or steps to achieve a particular
goal so this knowledge representation is
often used in expert systems or
intelligent agents performing tasks or
solving problems for example a
procedural knowledge representation for
making a cup of tea could be boiled
water in a kettle put a tea bag in a cup
pour the hot water into the cup wait for
a few minutes remove the tea bag and add
sugar or milk as desired so overall
knowledge representation is a critical
aspect of AI and different types of
knowledge representation helps to
organize knowledge in ways that the
computer system can effectively utilize
so guys what are your thoughts on how
effective knowledge representation is
for AI system do let me know in the
comment section if you like this video
share it with your friends before I sign
off make sure you subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to get all
the updates we'll be back with more such
interesting videos until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here